هذا هو أحد أهم
الأشياء لأنه عندما تنظر إلى
التقدم الذي أحرزه الأوكرانيون ،
فقد تم تلخيصه حقًا
بعبارة الناس عندما قالوا إن السلاف
يقولون إنه مجد للجيش الأوكراني
وما هم عليه  فعل هو أن الأوكرانيين
يتحركون بطريقة منهجية للغاية أه لقد
توقعوا أولاً بالطبع عاصمتهم
ثم انتقلوا إلى الشمال الشرقي أه
لتأمين المنطقة المحيطة بخاركيف
والآن استعادوا بالفعل
عاصمة المقاطعة الواحدة التي كان الروس يمتلكونها
ابنها والآن
ينتقلون إلى منطقة
يمكن أن يهددوا فيها حتى
سيطرة روسية على شبه جزيرة القرم ، لذلك بالطبع
أه أنت تعرف ربما حرفياً جسر
بعيد جدًا في الوقت الحالي بالنسبة لهم أه
لكن الأوكرانيين لديهم بالتأكيد
المسلم  وهم يفعلون شيئًا أه
فريدًا جدًا مبتكر جدًا مع
الأسلحة الغربية التي يتلقونها من
عمرة وأعتقد أنها ضخمة أه
مقاربة ابتكارية ضخمة للحرب التي
سنقوم بالدراسة
لبعض الوقت ، نعم الكثير من الزخم
معنويات كبيرة ، وأنا سعيد جدًا لأن
لدينا هذه الخريطة هناك لأنه إذا تمكنا من
إعادة هذا الأمر ، يمكنك معرفة
مكان ابنها في  الجنوب وأنت تعرف أن
هذه كانت جائزة إستراتيجية لروسيا في
ذلك الوقت لأنها كانت بمثابة جسر بري
بين أه أوكرانيا
وبالطبع
أم شبه جزيرة القرم التي تم
ضمها بشكل قانوني بشكل غير قانوني إلى روسيا في عام 2014. لذا
سيدريك ماذا تتوقع في المرة القادمة  خطوات
يجب أن تكون للجيش الأوكراني
خاصة مع العلم أن هناك
العديد من مجالات التفكير ،
نعم ، ستكون هذه عملية حضرية كبيرة
، كما تعلمون ، ربما
لن تكون حربًا حضرية كلاسيكية كما
رأيت في الحرب العالمية الثانية مع
معركة ستالينجراد  ولكن ما
ستراه هو عملية منهجية لتطهير
المباني من الأفخاخ المتفجرة أه من
الأفخاخ المفخخة المحتملة للألغام أه أشياء من هذا
القبيل ، والشيء الآخر الذي يتعين على
الأوكرانيين القيام به هو
أنهم سيضطرون إلى  مو  لقد تم
توجيه أنظمتهم إلى الأمام حتى يتمكنوا من مواجهة
أي مدفعية روسية محتملة
ستكون على الضفة الشرقية
لنهر نيبرو ، لذلك عندما تنظر إلى مكان
الأشياء على الخريطة الآن ، يمكنك أن
ترى أن الأوكرانيين قد انتقلوا إلى
ذلك  ضفة النهر أه يسيطرون الآن
على تلك المنطقة أه سيضطرون إلى
تطهير بعض القوات الروسية المتبقية
بعض القوات الروسية المتعثرة التي
لم تخرج من الضفة الغربية
لنهر أبريل ولكن تلك الموجودة هناك
على الأرجح إما أنفاق أو أه  أنت
تعلم أنه تم استبعادك من
المعركة ، لذا فهذه نقطة مهمة جدًا
بالنسبة للأوكرانيين ، سيتعين عليهم
تعزيز انتصارهم هنا ومن
أجل القيام بذلك ، سيتعين عليهم
المضي قدمًا بشكل منهجي
وبالطبع التأكد أيضًا من ذلك  قاموا بتوثيق
كل ما فعله الاندفاع في هذا
خلال هذه الفترة